this comes from a sort of fan story
researcher well it's like someone's is
their friends a mutual friend radial
Trent Eddie is a massive fan not that
old he will be born he'll be like sorry
but he's a massive fan of okra as we all
know and all you don't produce and I'm
like really
mega fan and so that so that the books
called that because a story in the book
is the title that I am was I was invited
to this big event with Oprah is getting
honored getting an award and so I
thought I've got to get here's my date
so I did and we got there and he was
just like friends he's like I've got I
want to get affordable I want to get
foot of open eyes like that might not
happen Eddie and I'm not going to go and
I am NOT going to be because I thought
if that does happen I'd have to go and
say okra my friend everyone I'm not
going to do that that you know you just
have to it might happen but just you
anyway I said then you know how when
people come up to me in bars and rubbing
dinner and they ask for photo and hope
stuff you get about that on my behalf
and you won't I see your point I still
want to put so so we were at the thing
and there's a big dinner and it was like
crazy like uploads at this sort of
central big table like Steven Spielberg
and we have Jesus and everybody and we
we would all like these tables going
around there's like satellites or you
know ken going around doctor and Barbara
Walters was hosting the thing and into
it and here's a check permit if he's and
here's Jesse now munchies sing anyway
and then it's just like full-on and then
at one point was and know we're going to
have a break and after the break
Oprah and we're like oh my god and so
Gayle or Plus friend came over to say
hello to us and we were this kind of
Siberia like table not we were kind of
near the lose that I could see Eddie a
bit like and so big Gail came over so
that was like venir nasib scale because
she's Oprah's best friend and then and
then she turned trying to talk to
someone and Eddie said editor her bum
was right there and I did take a picture
take a picture so I take a picture of
Gail's bomb and Eddie's head and then
and anyway and we still officially over
there and he said take a picture of what
put a flood away and me anything so had
this camera is zooming in and it wasn't
light as my cameras my husband grant so
I'm used to that
China's dim it and I got it her in focus
men suddenly she stood up as a [__] Ewok
deaf instead and now that ah Christ and
then I realize she was coming towards us
because she was going to the loo and I
was like Eddie she's coming she's gonna
come she's going to come right by here
you can totally come biscuits at this
moment could happen and so I'm trying to
unjam the same together here's the
kinetic and feel of energy is like a
tingly little thing and any and as any
stands up any kind of blocks her paw and
I'm trying to put all the thing and I
hear them in this little choirboy voice
going oprah there have a photo with you
it would be my dream so when you've got
to get bigger dream
[Laughter]
that's the picture it's not the picture
and it is one of the worst pictures I've
ever taken you have it for the air to
see and this is the picture of it Eddie
dreams of getting think it's perfectly
good you know it's absolutely what that
moment was like Oprah Oprah is a goddess
and she can only be half present with a
bloody man
[Music]